dont on en viendra à terme
et ce jour là tout sera différent
citoyen du monde
je suis là pour cent et votre tout ce
dont vous rêvez vous pouvez la voir
[Musique]
diana c'est comme si par un seul jour
s'étaient écoulées
j'ai jamais aimé les règles
réponse c'est toujours plus
maintenant c'est mon tour
barbara qu'est ce que tu as fait
[Musique]
il est arrivé malheur attendait
tu seras plus tôt seul maintenant tu vas
venir vivre avec nom et ton cousin
michael tu m'as dit que tu bosses pour
michael mais tu sais ce qu'on fait j'ai
toujours cru tout était différent
pas tant que ça
[Musique]
qui te tirer dessus les hommes de
bonheur
si tu leur donnes pas ce qu'ils veulent
tu sais très bien ce qui va se passer il
faut que tu sois mon côté
tu es mon frère et tu comptes faire quoi
à temps les italiens sont dans la place
depuis quoi près d'un siècle
et toi tu vas y mettre fin
[Musique]
il y aurait moyen je sais pas oublié
cette histoire non est ce que toi aussi
t'es qu'un pauvre crétin d'irlandais
[Musique]
étaient complets
tj comme si tu avais honte que tous les
mois au soir au hasard
à ton avis qui a balancé ton père
l'autre
vraiment aucune idée
ce bois
[Musique]
les enfants ou une fée marraine qui
veillent sur eux
c'est la petite fée qui est ailleurs as
autre
c'est n'est qu'une clause est
elle voulait grandir un peu trouvé lui
rêve d'explorer des terres inconnues
qui sont ces deux petits vagabond et
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait de mes enfants
cette histoire est née dit c'est celle
de frères et d'une soeur de petits
aventuriers alice et bidules et si vous
êtes chez moi
il doit payer tnt canal
as-tu été voir ton père comment va-t-il
c'est encore lui le patron pas vrai
[Musique]
les garçons perdus à votre service
les ongles de ta fille sont rangés
jusqu'à l'os on fera de toi une
demoiselle
alice j'en vivrai aux as tu devras payer
sa dette
il me faut plus de temps pour thomas
lüthi
plus tard n'est ce pas vite éteindre
arrêtez jamais brillé
[Musique]
il se retourne me coucher je vais aider
papa même si
[Applaudissements]
dites moi dites moi votre petit nom
c'est quoi
on a tous besoin d'un peu plus de
courage par moments
[Musique]
si pas encore le moment de grandir à
l'iss peter tu verras
[Musique]
2k games n'est pas celui là à mon pote
celui là il est spécial c'est sur
invitation g1 paul d'un bosco genre
nouveau riche le fric lui sort par les
oreilles
bon on vient de l'autre bout du monde
qu'est ce que tu as prévu pour nous tu
aura jamais rien vu de pareil
quelqu'un devrait être là c'est quoi
tout ça qu'est ce qui s'est passé ici et
si je faisais partie du truc tu fais ton
pote qui était en train de lui parler je
le reconnais pas si bien qu on est en
russie avec un mec qu'en fait tu connais
de rien t'es dingue ou quoi c'est qu'un
jeu c'est sûrement pas rigoler il se
fout de nous là il faut pas nous jeter
pas attendre tout le monde doit se
détendre et en faut qu'on sorte et qu'on
se mettre en sécurité
qu'est ce qu'il fait ou torturés je sais
que deux facettes
mais je ne connais pas leurs étoiles
dans no more attendait
tu sais combien ils payent pour gratter
des gens comme se faire découper en
morceaux diffusés ça
[Applaudissements]
c'était une nuit bizarre je me reconnais
plus
votre gilet de sauvetage se trouve dans
une pochette sous votre siège si son
utilisation s'avère nécessaire
amener les sangles autour de votre
taille tirer sur les sangles jusqu'à ce
que le gilet soit bien ajusté comme nous
vous le montre merci de votre attention
nous allons bientôt décoller des
événements nous déchire en mars
j'aime être sous x c'est ce que ça veut
dire
et quelqu'un il remet en place divers
pourquoi le jeu parfois on peut être
celle des deux pianos c'est dur d'être
seul avec le mans fait attention
qu'est ce qui te dis que je ne suis pas
un seul type je sais rien
[Musique]
spécial
qu'est ce que t'en sais
c'est difficile d'être heureusement je
pense que j'ai saigné refait personnes
utilisent son visage public aujourd'hui
parfois nous masquer plus joli que ce
qui se trouve derrière je me dis qu'il
n'ya pas deux
toutes les pièces ne soit pas
parfaitement
et d'un coup tout et pau
[Musique]
c'est qu'on sert à rien
on sert plus à rien
[Musique]
les habitants des quartiers ils ont même
eu l'espoir qu'on vienne les aider c'est
fini
ce qu'il en soit on entend des signes je
serai quoi serait quoi traire
là on a envie de nickel réseau nous ont
foutu me donne une vraie info la sint il
300 kg acheté trouve inexact c'est
impossible at it came est enregistrée
fait comme on nous l'a appris j'ai
bouché par la suite pas savoir
quoi je devrais risquer ma carrière
parce nous donne les moyens de
travailler il faut arrêter avec les
citer tous le monde sont - le préfet le
premier voulait juste faire la une du
journal pour faire le bon tu veux
devenir officier fait cette opération
devant les chefs d'accusation raquette
et trafic de drogue en bande organisée
c'est pasqua
ça fait 20 ans que je fais ce métier moi
je crois tu sais que tu sais rien
utilisez un des quartiers nord
on a failli crever là bas
[Musique]
toi tu rentres chez toi tu risque rien
thomas parole
tu fais ce métier je le ferai je
comprends pas pourquoi je comprends pas
comment arriver à l'antenne
[Musique]
on est chez nous max nouveau départ
c'est sa neuvième nouveau départ les
déménagements
je te promets nous avons un nouvel élève
monsieur mac graff max maga le fils de
tom mcgrath alors pourquoi tout le monde
sait plus de trucs sur mon père que moi
dans ce trouble tu connaissais mon père
il faut que je sache pour son travail
ton père travailler sur la possibilité
de stocker plus d'énergie plus qu'aucun
être humain ne peut l'imaginer il était
sur le point de faire une découverte
qu'est ce qui m'arrive
max non t'approche pas toi je m'appelle
speed toi tu sais par les annales ma
mère va monter est ce que ma mère est
dangereux non non fait massa au mas
froide il faut nettoyer
il faut nettoyer sa vie de mon cher
c'est toi qui m'a fait ça non c'est ton
père qui t'a donné ses pouvoirs je suis
là pour te montrer comment les utiliser
allez on commence
max qui peut utiliser ton énergie de
plein de manières
tu peux courir plus vite
[Musique]
être plus fort
et a pas encore vu le fin du fin c'est
quoi oh
alors ça c'est énorme de rien
mais sofia ça va tout oui j'ai juste
peur d'être en retard pour moi ça
commence à être ennuyeux mon cours de
zumba la créature féminine semble faire
augmenter ton pot tu devrai éviter le
combat et toi peut-être que tu devrais
la firme jiwa elle te met en colère les
ultra bling ce sont là pour détruire la
terre il n'ya que ton énergie qui pourra
les en empêcher on est là joe namath
j'arrive pas à croire que je vais faire
ça
tu dois apprendre à contrôler ces
pourvois regarde maintenant à gauche non
on va à droite accord
complique vraiment peiné
ton père voulait sauver le monde
[Musique]
au tour maintenant maxi
c'est une valise et le mode turbo
tu vas bien oui
c'était pas pire que d'habitude
[Musique]
dieu bénit chacun d'eux
suivez-moi
[Musique]
balivernes il a connu quelques échecs
c'est vrai tu n'en as pas connu vous
avez un nouveau livre en tête bien sûr
qu'il aura mal homme s'était éteinte je
n'ai plus d'imagination allons-nous
avoir des ennuis lors bien sûr que non
je vous ai demandé de ne pas me déranger
quand je travaille la veille de noël les
esprits envahissent la nuit
écoutez monsieur dickens des voleurs des
prostituées c'est ridicule ces gens
n'ont pas leur place dans l'élite
charles est reparti est reparti c'est
l'histoire d'un navarre qui la veille de
noël rencontre d esprit d sorte de guide
surnaturel quel est le titre
balivernes où la misère du vieil amant
des fantômes de noël chansons de noël
la balade de noël peut être trouvé le
nom du personnage et il apparaîtra
scratch ce qu'on gère
[Musique]
perdre un set l'argent ne pousse pas
dans les arbres
monsieur scrooge quel plaisir de vous
rencontrer
ce plaisir n'est pas partagé vous et moi
allons faire des choses extraordinaires
ensemble vous faites vous pour les
rendre aussi vivant j'arrive presque à
voir et entendre vos personnages
si vous l'aviez déjà écrit il serait
possible de l'imprimer et de les
distribuer aussi peu d'eau je ne peux
pas de finir je n'écrirai plus jamais
peur les personnages ne font pas ce que
je veux c'est moi l'auteur de l'histoire
gvt holding libre et joyeux
qu'est ce que ça signifie
en cette saison d'espoir nous
rejetterons rien ni personne tout le
monde sera fier
selon le remettre à l'imprimeur avant 9
heures vous n'avez même pas écrit la fin
un très joyeux noël à tous et chacun ça
suffit on se remet au travail
que dieu bénisse chacun de nous
[Musique]
je pense à l'algérie je pense à nos
vingt ans c'est mais pas beaucoup et
pourtant rester ensemble dès qu'on se
croise et depuis toujours c'était comme
ça ils sont tous là à parler morts
bernard parent est oui bien sûr qui peut
être là le croire car c'était toi
[Musique]
toujours été comme ça une famille de
cinq ans mais nous a même pas présenter
sa femme il était tellement jeune fou
furieux rigide
tu ferais quoi si longtemps pêché treuil
tu ferais quoi si on occupe depuis on se
bat pour la france
il est comme il est mais il a toujours
été gentil avec moi c'était écrit tout
ça l'ennuie des corvées ceux qui
buvaient jusqu'à ce qu'ils s'écroulent
les tours de garde le soleil qui tourne
elle seule la poussière mais le reste
venant elle est belle au jeu
pas des hommes qui font des trucs
pareils c'est des chiens c'est un peu
pâle raconter parce qu'il n'y a pas de
mots pour raconter ça
[Musique]
y'a pas de mots on peut pas le dire
on n'aime pas ses nationaux
[Musique]
des hommes les hommes avaient fait
simple
[Musique]